unrealistic I ideal of the woman a  bikini model svelte but still curvy some  of it was natural some of it was not so  again unrealistic and that was just what  I grew up thinking was the ideal for men  when you are in your late 20s early 30s  and things aren't working out in love or  acting you just like want to make a  change and you're like well this is the  problem this is the one area I'm not  proportionate you know or whatever it's  it's so silly to look back on and now I  mean I love having them out like you  said like you wanted to be more womanly  and proportionate but then when there  was actual intimacy and interaction with  them you're like  I'm saying you know and I've like made  sure I did like the doctor like after  you get implants in you're supposed to  like move them so they don't get hard  and get encapsulated and so I did like  twice as much I was like forget the pain  like I'm making these girls natural you  know